what is going on there citizens the reject
Nation we're gonna watch a bad batch episode
12. Michael are you excited I'm so excited
multihouse.io we had syllabus leave alive
we had clones yeah
Commandos yes hey subscribe subscribe like
subscribe and comment if you want to have
great Star Wars discussions guys let's uh
watch the show now we're gonna have the best
time I'm so excited this is Greg's favorite
television
[Music] all right
The Outpost like where you deliver mail like
where the Clone Rebellion is based please
give it to me Hondo is hiring then oh I like
Whistler oh my God good tone that's you know
when you're in a good tone across
finally I thought they couldn't renew his
contract or something yeah I'm lieutenant
your commanding officer for this Mission we're
heading to the Imperial Depot on Barton 4
high value cargo store there has been targeted
by local insurgents where to secure it until
it's transferred weeks yummy I hate his face
so much oh fantastic more clones problem sir
I don't like used equipment I can't you say
that about lovers but what did you do yeah
I don't think we heard each other no you were
you were going one way
[Music] that's LA right now okay I'm telling
me man yeah
[Music] now illum's being turned into Starkiller
base come on no no no no no I'm pretty sure
we're getting kyber crystals now you got to
get better at your game man
you got this [__]
dumb Imperials so much I hope he just goes
AWOL man they're really like let's make our
last five episodes look freaking awesome
what the mortise bird no I thought I think
it is a thousand percent trust me so now we're
stepping into the thing [Laughter] where is
your supervisor you must be our reinforcements
we expected you 36 rotations ago oh God Kurt
Russell we work on the Empire's scheduled
Trooper not yours it's Commander where are
the rest of your men dad your feelings will
be dealt with later
you uh know the lieutenant well for about
two hours two hours too long I bet oh my God
he's gonna bond with this is actually really
helpful for Crosshair yeah the name's mayday
wait a second Crosshair welcome to MayDay
The Outpost
nope don't remember mayday I'll give you a
layer of the land
we are in the thing yeah we're told
oh you have no idea wanted that myself every
day you don't know apparently it's above a
Clone Trooper's pay grade can I actually be
kyber you might be right
don't go far unless what's in the ice kills
you first either way it'll make them happy
oh
cut them off I do feel this season needed
more Crosser yeah it's gripping when he's
on screwed it really is [Applause] feels like
a real Soldier you know he fought in Stalingrad
oh cool yeah
I love the setting here
no he's got a Crosshair though
[Music]
[Music] if it is kyber crystals I don't think
it is that might be who knows be adventurous
Greg I have theories it could be kyber crystals
it could be a Jedi and sabotaging them trying
to stop the Empire from getting their hands
on the crystals that will be used to fuel
the Death Star [Music] foreign
must have fled on foot into the mountain pass
oh this is neat oh that's how they should
have passed all defenses
I'm loving the vibe of this one a lot we don't
have the Manpower or gear for a mission beyond
the perimeter especially just to recover a
few crates up to you to determine what is
of value to the Empire then I need all your
men for this Mission yeah [__] Outpost
vulnerable to another attack this task Falls
to you too and you two alone recover the cargo
is that clear how does the Empire attract
such pompous [__] they recruit from all
the Ivy League schools yeah it's like what
happened you guys weren't like pompous [__]
before the Empire now it's like nothing but
it's just like one thing canonically that
like they're so bad at what they do why would
you ever replace the Clones who are just so
good at what they do
well it is n't carrying dead weight
not to die on your watch
this is a fun little pairing I know I hope
they fall in love Go Disney maybe one day
it's been a rock it's okay what were you saying
about dead weights [Laughter]
is I don't feel like carrying your body back
to the Outpost I guess I'll give it a shot
I like him I know I like mayday's attitude
a lot I wish I had the proper equipment for
this the empires ignored all my requests I
guess all clones have had to since the war
nail that into the snow it's ice don't pick
up your food [__] wait until I tell you
then lift it real slow like all the way around
the bend if I don't hear a boom then I'll
know
it worked
[Laughter]
[Music] and then they kill off Crosshair walk
away
then he steps on us
you guys gonna have to cuddle up keep corn
keep warm
I hope Crosshair does not kill Mayday I like
mayday's attitude a lot oh
Splinter's Cell nice
I love these multiple episodes of Crosshair
getting to just team up and go ham yeah with
another Clone Commander question everything
he's doing thank you
perfect shot damn
you guys are a great team yeah right
I love it they're the snow people okay [Music]
my favorite video game trick
good job you guys can recover the cargo now
that's so good
you guys must be freezing I can hear them
going Burr if you listen really close take
off your helmet in this weather your ears
would be so cold yeah we've been risking Our
Lives to recover equipment we could have been
wearing this whole time oh that is cold oh
man
Avalanche
oh shoot it Crosshair
that'll stop it
[Music]
wow [Music] oh no better just helped save
crosshair's life and just like that crosshair's
heart grew three sizes
that you're wishing you had your helmet on
right about now huh
is he gonna try to save him definitely yeah
his death might be the linchpin that Sparks
the rebellion and crosshairs heart
oh man if he dies he's gonna kill the other
Imperial officer
oh no no don't kill Mayday I love this guy
all right I won't make it [Laughter]
oh [__] oh my God Crosser don't you tell
him in my heart again man oh man
his bald head must be freezing freezing yeah
[Music]
oh the cheeks and the ears you feel it
this is great oh damn yeah no I love this
one [Music] all those elements man versus
nature or they are elements yeah
and they're gonna come back to a rude thankless
bureaucrat [Music] they are doing the cuddle
up
[Music] remind me they do they don't they
all have a bit of extra enhanced strength
uh they all have their own kind of unique
yeah yeah but due to them but generally speaking
Yeah oh
follow me
this [__] yeah it was David Bowie looking
[__]
step aside step aside dude I hope you get
shot right now
with those crates oh
this is it for Crosshair yeah about time you
two returned
it's a medical attention yeah I see you didn't
retrieve the crates which means you failed
this guy is such help him that would be a
waste of the Empire's resources he'll die
he served his purpose as a soldier of the
empire oh chose the wrong words you didn't
hear me he he is expendable as are you oh
and if you speak to me again with such disrespect
I'll see to it you meet a similar fate Club
poor guy man he needed it yeah [Music] [__]
he's gonna do it yes
I think you sent all those workers back yeah
right yeah never mind
oh [__] is he gonna go all Rambo on them
right now he can't he's too he's way too [Music]
yes
damn this is like some Film Festival [__]
that we're watching right now you know hello
ct9904 or do you prefer Crosshair
uh what's the objective here related to Omega
who are you remain calm cooperate and you
might survive
spooky she kind of sounds a little like Omega
she does doesn't she
I thought that the last episode that'd be
kind of an interesting uh like she's kind
of derived from her DNA Django or a combination
of the two yeah or maybe they just had a kid
that would be a lot easier wow uh man that
was great um do you remember last episode
when we talked what happened last episode
well last episode we talked about my theory
that you rudely laughed off that Crosshair
will be the one to save Omega when Omega is
inevitably captured by these people um oh
yeah did it just so happened that his entire
motivation is so simple location
now it sounds so stupid still it sounds so
worse oh and there's no way no they didn't
totally change his moral compass I don't see
it put him in space uh impossible yeah and
then they're gonna write it you're reaching
right away together on the Zillow Beast mark
my quest with baby girl guinto oh that was
great no you're right I think that's gonna
happen yeah um I really hope they don't finish
that or they I really don't want us to have
the conclusion of Omega being safe at the
end of the season um I feel like the stakes
deserve to be higher the interesting Mike
it's pointed towards your mouth a little more
yeah how's that yeah it's better than facing
your the bottom of your chin whatever I have
a beautiful chin anyway uh yeah no I thought
I thought it was really fun to have I mean
this like Beautiful War Story like yeah these
two old veteran comrades um and then just
to be treated like that immediately Upon returning
um it just it was so well done and I think
you know when Crosshair is talking to mayday
it's not just May Day right like it's the
the collective like Mayday just represents
the collective clone experience um well it's
also encompassing the events that he had encountering
Cody yeah you know yeah where it's the continuation
of well you know Cody went AWOL this guy stayed
behind and continued to do his job and this
is what happens yeah um I mean this is the
most overt exposure I think he's maybe not
the he's seen some bad treatment of the Clones
but this is at least from what we've seen
of seeing Crosshair scene [__] yeah this
is the worst like they they're like yeah they're
good nope equipment for the new guys you guys
suffer insults or lives don't matter this
guy just talks that this guy is literally
like prejudiced against clones he treats them
like they are not human whatsoever which is
which is interesting because when they first
introduced the bad batch I mean even the first
like I think it's season two the Clone Wars
when we first hear the phrase bad batch uh
really and that's when yeah it's it's in reference
to uh when fives Echo and and Company are
in training and trying to get this is in season
two yeah season two it's really early on now
it's not the bad batch as a group as much
as other clones talking about like oh yeah
you don't want to be like one of the bad backs
okay uh of course 99 being like the official
uh yeah exactly um we didn't even entertain
the idea that they could be epic and awesome
like this bad batch but um but I feel like
there is within the bad batch I mean even
they call them the regs yeah regulars like
um I think it it it's been fun to watch that
perception of their fellow clones change like
sure where they thought they were better than
I think in some ways because they were different
and because also because they were looked
at as less than by I think a lot of the Clones
and now they're all in the same boat um I'm
on a boat um yeah uh it's going fast uh and
if you don't do something about it yeah might
get decommissioned by the Empire so um yeah
I mean they're setting up I mean we have what
two episodes left uh yes I think so yeah yeah
I mean it's um that got a lot to accomplish
I don't think we're seeing the Clone Rebellion
uh I don't think so last time I was like yeah
I wonder how they're going to wrap this up
neatly was during the final season of Game
of Thrones and well we all know how that turned
out yeah I think that this particular episode
is uh one of my favorites of the bad batch
in total yeah um again this show proves that
as much as I like last episodes a little beast
and and surprisingly it the main characters
were the bad badges this season continues
to prove that yeah when it's not the bad match
you're the main characters it is I mean techno
Crosshair was introduced as as a member of
the bad batch so it still is a bad batch focus
and it is interesting seeing his experience
this the this constant conflict this guy is
in because he's had a very main objective
of good soldiers follow orders you know and
even that gets echoed back to him ah Echo
and with this character Mayday I really enjoyed
his personality and presence I kind of fell
in love with that character right away because
as much as he sounds like every other clone
we've heard he he has to be Bradley Baker
yeah he has this um it's not exactly full
this is sarcastic it's a bit of a sarcastic
nature to him um a bit apathetic but you could
just tell he's just so dreary and worn out
and I loved this kind of cynical approach
to life that he's happy you can tell he still
cares like he's just he's got that kind he's
just got all these interesting complexities
that he and he's like such a physical demonstration
of it all around and I loved seeing them interact
and of course the way they do the visual language
with animation with cross hair I thought this
was the best looking bad batch episode because
of the I mean I love I'm a sucker for um ice
no Landscapes and the atmosphere and because
it's always beautiful but harsh you know like
you got that that two opposing uh elements
to deal with or the the way you take that
in right and when you have characters on a
lot of times when we're saying like oh this
looks gorgeous and beautiful we're usually
talking about like setting establishments
Landscapes whatever but this I thought they
really brought the character animation and
expression to life and that's what I was saying
like that film festival comic because I was
like this was very artistic it reminded me
a lot of like the the last three episodes
yeah exactly where there's just this cinematic
bump up yeah um and you know it it really
even the colors feel like a little richer
and a little deeper which I'm sure is exacerbated
because of of the snow um because they don't
go into the crosshairs backstory in this episode
so I weirdly felt like this could have been
some like short film that would they would
just release you know yeah that's true like
you need no contact you don't uh just know
where it takes what it takes place yeah but
other than that you don't need a no crosshairs
backstory or anything no it's it and it reminded
me of I mean some of my favorite episodes
of The Clone Wars are just following the relationship
between clones and them going out learning
I mean that's how we we learn to love fives
and Echo and this guy like um and this episode
kind of felt like the two are like watching
the the bond that comes from the trauma of
War yeah only without the at least we can
be proud about what we did and it was for
a greater cause now you have these soldiers
that like everything that they do comes with
just resentment and a sense of like I mean
it reminds me a lot of and I'm sure this is
what they're going for but like in the Vietnam
War when veterans would get home and like
be spat on at the exact part like uh and and
look down upon by a bunch of these snooty
you know that's why Rambo kill everyone in
that town yeah I mean or one person
people often think he went on a massacre but
yeah he actually did not he passed out he
went nap time uh but yeah he massacred everyone
on the face uh what do you think reject Nation
about Greg imagining in his mind of mass slaughtering
some people thought and that was just kind
of the Mis memories that people
people have that with
Rambo or they think he murdered the whole
town yeah of course he did um no I only murdered
a couple people I don't think he murdered
anyone I don't remember now yeah Rambo is
actually a Quaker it's a non-violent yeah
he's a pacifist he's brilliant misunderstood
yeah uh yeah I I think and also they just
they had characters that I thought represented
the World building to such a strong definition
like whoever this dick wad was uh the the
lieutenant he was such a pompous [__]
and I I loved it I loved that just you got
these three people yeah and they are the representation
of where we are in the state of this world
and I think for a follow-up to clone wars
this is one of the better episodes of doing
it because you know when you think about the
Clones they went through they were they were
such a beloved characters and then you watch
the tragedy unfold and it's like oh they got
brainwashed and they killed the Jedi look
at them they're bad and then you see that
damn they they were just like abused you know
they were straight up they were no different
than droids in the mind they were treated
that way yeah when they are much more like
that they're human human well they are human
yeah I mean it's argue with you man yeah if
there's a clone of you made would you consider
that clone human or does it have to be the
birth of God do you consider me human in some
ways can I am I allowed to disagree with you
on something yeah or contractually I don't
think we've had that yet um Rambo death no
no that was not an art like I personally am
really sick of the Imperial like standard
character like something I really appreciated
about Clone Wars is that when we met what
are you disagree with me oh I'm disagreeing
with I thought like this character was no
different than every single other oh definitely
officer yeah and and I'm I'm getting to the
point where like I think we need to see some
of the redeemed like like you have like your
Lauren um you know who's uh are of course
in A New Hope and then was the the narrator
for yeah like I want to see characters that
have a little bit more depth to them and that
can can still achieve that same ends where
they're they're not respectful to clones but
it's not just like this random bigotry there's
like a more of a reason for it like well how
good of a soldier could you have been if you
turned on your generals like how can I trust
you not to do that to me oh dude I like I
completely agree with you I know we're fighting
it we're trying to fight right I agree I agree
with you I I just think that the The Stereotype
of this guy was fitting for this episode no
yeah of course that's what I think I think
the problem is from bad batch to Rebels to
literally all pieces yeah it's so I mean like
and then you just continue it with like clocks
and half the time yeah half the time they
are and they are just like a hawks where you're
like you're obviously like trying to present
bde but you are not yeah
I feel like they did that with the CIS where
they broke that a little bit or like when
we started to meet like the other side it
was like oh look at these interesting characters
that have like Dimensions to them and um you
know uh well Greg all in all I'm so excited
for the last two episodes um are they a two-parter
I don't know oh yeah yeah yeah um they are
because they're like mandalorians airing we
gotta just wrap it up I'm telling you final
episode predictions or final two episodes
we're gonna see grogu we're gonna see Hondo
we're definitely gonna spend most of it with
Sid hahaha there will be Nerf nuggets there
will not be Riot racing we will figure out
who's in the back to tank in Jedi Survivor
um do you think thrawn thrawn thrawn fee thrawn
is fee and Benny and Benny and the Jets will
come back with their explosions I know I know
Benny with their explosives and they're gonna
blow a hole in the Clone station and save
baby Yoda and that's what's gonna happen his
name grogu is grogu the child anyway what
do you think is gonna happen uh I think it's
gonna have uh 90 good qualities and then maybe
one percent of I wish they did this yeah um
but hey man to me this was like a as this
might have been this might have been my favorite
bad batch episode weirdly enough nice I feel
like you've said that four times already uh
but I guess I can change people can change
this is one of my favorites I like I so far
my favorites of the Season undoubtedly Cody
are the two with the crosshairs they are of
this season those two are my favorites I still
really liked Riot racing I got way too much
crap that was weird that was really fun it
was a really fun episode um that's my favorite
one of my favorite tech episodes ever but
in terms of like I I think these are two wonderfully
isolated episodes one final question is there
anything Sid can do in the last two episodes
to redeem herself to you other than die nope
that's all I had yeah I like are they gonna
is Sid gonna be the one to show up at the
end of the day and get them off the planet
it would be funny probably if they if the
if the Empire's hunting them again because
they want to know where that ship is yeah
they hunt them they kill Sid's bar hide out
and they kill Sid and then they find out that
Sid left all her Fortune to the batch oh interesting
yeah no that's not gonna happen no no she
was probably set it to have her Fortune be
set inflamed not really even anyway they really
set up the fee character to do nothing huh
yeah it's bad batch that's the show yeah that's
what they do
uh but what if it's like a Multiverse where
there's a branch timeline where fee please
okay we're not doing this anyway uh thank
you guys for watching I'm Michael Tessler
I'm Greg Alba and this is the real X [Music]